Minnesota Democrat Amy Klobuchar is a
member of the Senate Judiciary Committee
one of three congressional committees
investigating Russian influence in the
last election top lawyers from Facebook
Twitter and Google will appear before
the House and Senate intelligence
committees on Wednesday last month
Facebook turned over more than 3000 ads
it says were brought by a Russian troll
farm and seen by about 10 million users
senator Klobuchar our co-sponsor the
bipartisan honest ads Act that would
require social media platforms to reveal
who buys those political ads she's with
us only on CBS this morning senator good
morning thank you very much let's start
with the breaking news this morning it
appears that Paul Manafort Trump's
former campaign manager is turning
himself in to the special count Council
what do you think this means for the
Russia investigation well first of all
we'll wait till these charges are filed
but we do know that mana 4 was the top
position in the campaign he was the
chairman we also know he left that
position in part because of his dealings
with foreign governments we know that he
failed to register under the foreign
agent act he did not register when he
was supposed to for representing the
former government in Ukraine the Russian
related government and we also know that
he may have had some shady business
dealings money laundering there's been
reports of wired transfers in the past
in 2012 and 2013 so there's a lot to go
on there and the issue is even if he is
charged with something unrelated to
Russia it could just be the beginning
you're a former prosecutor you know what
how grand juries to operate tell me
where we are in this investigation with
what's happening this day you know I
don't think people really know exactly
where we are which is appropriate
because this Bob Miller has been
conducting this investigation
professionally he hasn't been
politicizing it or working with members
of Congress but we know that this is the
beginning and that it is a broad
investigation and that I'd like to
remind people that this started under a
Republican run Justice Department who
knew that there were facts out there in
Rod Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney
General put him in charge of this
investigation so he could do his work
based on reports from
and intelligence agencies that had
gathered ample information that there
was Russia was trying to interfere in
our election and may have been working
with the Trump campaign yeah the
president calls this a whole witch-hunt
that there's nothing to it any questions
the timing does the timing bother you is
are getting ready to concentrate on tax
reform no and I consider it a truth hunt
and not a witch hunt I think we owe it
to our democracy a senator portman with
just saying in that clip this is about
our the integrity of our own democracy
this idea that we're self-governing that
we don't have foreign countries
influencing the outcome of our elections
so the question has always been about
collusion though with the Trump campaign
which still remains an open question
right right but we know all of these
things now that we didn't know back in
November the fact that there was this
meeting that Paul mana 4 was present at
where a lawyer who has relations with
the Russian government had her talking
points that we've now heard reports that
she gave them to the Kremlin we know
that the Attorney General spoke to the
Russian ambassador right after
discussion with President Obama on the
sanctions we know that the National
Security Advisor resigned because of his
dealings with Russia that phone calls he
made it's just one thing after another
people being fired dealings with Russia
and so I don't know what Muller is gonna
find which is good this is a criminal
investigation as a prosecutor what's
your big question that you want to know
there are many I get that but what's
your big question what I want to know is
how far this went who was involved and
who gave the orders turning to the
honest legislation that you are
co-sponsoring on Capitol Hill this week
or some of the CEOs of these big
companies are they cooperating are they
welcoming this legislation I think that
would be a far cry that they're not
welcoming it but I cannot tell you how
important this is yes it is Facebook
Google and Twitter right this is about
national security we know the ads were
purchased in rubles but it is also about
Americans having the right to know who's
trying to influence them ads that are
run on your show that are political ads
when people buy ads you have to have I'm
Amy Klobuchar I approve this message but
you also have to keep those ads and
register them
online so campaign since them
journalists can see him not true in the
Wild West of the Internet we love the
Internet it's brilliant but we know that
we have to keep up with the times one
point four billion dollars was spent in
online ads but this is and there's no
tracking of it it has I just went back
then are they opposing this legislation
they have started to take they've
started to take some responsibility they
are doing some things to change their
practices they didn't take it seriously
at first they did not and they many of
them have admitted it but now is the
time for them to support our bill we
can't have enforcement if they're just
doing it on their own and we also
they're still not dealing with issue ads
which of course dominate the internet
and we're dominating TV they're still
not agreeing to do though this appears
to be a giant loophole in campaign
finance laws it is humongous
our campaign finance laws were set up at
a time when we didn't have any of these
kinds of ads now we need to update them
our laws have to be as sophisticated as
those that are trying to influence our
electorate and we're not talking here
about you posting a cat video you'll not
that I think you would video these are
paid political ads paid how much of a
difference you expect it would make it
would make a big difference in terms of
people being able to track them we
wouldn't Jenna let's everyone be able to
see these Russian ads we would have been
able to figure out this is the beginning
of monitoring and regulating these big
five Internet companies at the beginning
because we do these are brilliant
companies they've done great things for
America but in some ways they're a
victim of their own success and they
have to take responsibility for this and
I'm glad some of them are doing some
things but they have to understand that
we need to have laws so that the laws
can be enforced Thank You senator Clovis
are the honest out attack thank you for
to have you at the table